(audience applauding)
Well, first up,
our story today, it's gonna be wedding bells
for Machine Gun Kelly and Megan Fox.
But we got details on that ring.
And I liked finding out what they were.
People reports that Machine Gun Kelly designed it himself.
He also designed it with thorn tips,
so that if Megan tries to take it off,
it hurts a little bit.
Okay, well.
That feels very in keeping with them,
a little torture, a little mm-mm.
The ring is actually two rings,
one emerald for her birthstone, one diamond for his,
another detail I liked knowing.
And then the two are attracted to each other
by a magnet that snaps them together.
What's this couple gonna do next, Rossie?
I'm here for this.
I'm here for it too. I'm glad they found each other.
Because they said after they got engaged,
they drank each other's blood-
Yeah.
Cute, okay. And then-
(audience laughs)
Which again I couldn't tell
if they were being jokey or serious, I never know.
But I'm here for all of it.
I'm here for it, but I don't know about a thorn that hurts
when you take it off.
I like to kick it old school and just not to be able
to take it off when I eat too much bacon.
You know what I mean? Like that's the way it should be.
Well, that's why there's S and M.
(Ross and audience laughs)
I'm less S and M, and more M and M.
(audience and Drew laughs)
That's kinda how I roll.
(audience applauding)
Touche.
But I really am glad that they found each other.
Me too.
Next up we've got some news
on one of my favorite bodily functions.
It's laughter.
Yay, laughter!
I love this story so much-
I know.
I can't even handle it.
Get ready for it, Upworth reports,
scientists have actually discovered,
at least 65 different species of animals,
they love a good laugh too.
Gorillas, chimpanzees, seals, dogs, cows, rats,
they all get the giggles.
Can you imagine how cute, just picture like a fox giggling,
can you even picture it?
Well guess what? We have video of foxes giggling.
Look at this.
(foxes giggling)
(audience applauding)
Okay. Sorry, is that not?
And this is the kind of news I need in my day.
I need to see that fox.
I didn't even know that animals really could laugh.
Do you know I try to like make jokes to my chihuahuas,
they won't even throw me a bone, nothing.
But now I can't stop thinking about animals
I wanna see laugh.
Like don't you wanna see a dolphin giggle?
I feel like that's what they're doing.
(Drew imitates dolphin whistle)
That's right!
(audience laughs)
You know what? I didn't know you could do a dolphin sound.
I do dolphin.
What other animals can you do?
I don't know, test me.
Okay, do a horse.
(Drew imitating horse whinny)
Okay, throw one at me. That's good.
Horsey.
(Ross imitates horse whinny)
You're a horse.
My horse is gay-
I was gonna say.
(Ross imitates horse whinny)
(audience applauding)
One is a gay horsey.
Hey!
But I will be channeling the visual of that fox
for the rest of my life.
Yeah.
Like that is goals right there.
Well, next up, I asked the news division,
I said listen, we have got to get some information
om why this phenomenon is taking place.
Why, two days ago, did I not know about Wordle,
and now I can't open a cupboard without Wordle popping out?
Can I tell you?
This morning Willy said, "We've got to play Wordle."
I had never heard about it until this morning,
and now were talking about it, everyone is.
So I'm like origins story, okay?
'Cause if you're not already on the Wordle train,
and I know it just sounds like a word
that's like nonsense, but listen to this.
It's not nonsense, The New York Times reports
that Wordle is the daily word game on your phone
that's become an absolute viral runaway hit.
Not to me mistaken by an app, it's only a link right now.
But wait to see what's coming with this.
It was created last fall by a software engineer
named Josh Wardle, and it was a sweet gift for his partner,
because she loved word games and she loved it so much,
Josh ended up sharing it with the world.
And on November first, 90 people played,
and today over 2.5 million people play worldwide.
Yes.
And its growing bigger and bigger by the hour,
not just the day.
Why the Wordle fever? It's fun, it's quick, it's free.
It's new every day, it gives you a tiny win
and its sharable.
Players are sharing cute little emoji boards
to show their scores every day.
Rossie?
Well I love this because you can actually only play it
once a day.
(upbeat theme music)